okay think what oh alright I was missing
something here oh and got it kill that
ah one of these days I will get better
remembering everything that I need to do
to do this properly so this that's a
little closer odds are the camera is
gonna be a little bit wobbly and it's
some of the adjustments to the new setup
and where I'm now located so I hope
everyone is doing alright I did see that
we had our first donation the shoe and
the supe super chat from Microraptor and
for the amount that you donated I did do
a quick google to find out what that
wasn't in USD that gets you any question
that you want answered go for it so know
that you have that so despite the
seriousness of what it is that I'm
raising money for and why I'm right now
that's why I started hang on my lights
isn't on I thought this looked weird err
that's that's better I think is that
better
I don't know I'm going with it so um
anyways despite the seriousness of why I
felt the need to do this despite the
series of seriousness of the cause that
I am raising money for and everything
going on the tone of this is going to be
fairly light that might be part of the
issue I'm I'm sorry folks I'm trying to
figure this out unfortunately I've
calibrated these lights for my normal
camera and I live stream from my phone
yeah you're just gonna have to to work
with me on this
anyways tone of this is going to be
pretty light-hearted the reason for that
despite the the potential incongruity
the the simple fact is that with
everything going on the reason why you
should be donating these this money I'm
not a voice you should be listening to
on that topic I'm I'm just not so I
don't want to be the voice for that so
instead I'm gonna do sort of my normal
thing but if you look in the description
I've got it laid out as well so
donations under tender oh here we go
did you get to check out the writing I
sent oh my gosh thank you for reminding
me on that I haven't I need to I'm sorry
so the any donations under $10 USD that
gets you a question answered tend to
anything anything under 20 I will eat a
random bird II bought every flavor bean
which I'm now gonna have to do and 20
and up I will take a shot and in
addition like at 10 and 20 you can also
ask a question so have a boy I am I've
not I've not touched these things in a
while because last time it yeah it went
badly so let me see this is Oh God oh
this might be a vomit oh jeez huh around
since Christmas yeah since before then
you go figure I haven't gotten rid of
them okay good cause good cause good
cause
hmm gamma Derrida haha Oh God that's the
worst thing about the vomit ones they
don't hit you right off they do ah hmm
this is just water for the record oh guy
oh those are the worst because they
start out they're kind of oddly sweet
it's almost like you got tangerine or
something but then it hits you I'm back
in ah like after you've had in your
mouth for a while
God oh thank you randomness finally
finished Buffy oh the tears oh dear if
you want a recommendation on any kind of
continuation I am NOT going to recommend
the Buffy Season eight comic books
however however I am going to recommend
Frey which is a comic book continuation
of Buffy but it is a more detached set
in the far future it's very cool
actually Liz and I read that fairly
recently and did a did a podcast on it
on tough like a girl over on the fire
and water podcast network how am I still
managing to self promote during this Oh
on the other thing if you want to donate
anything but for whatever reason aren't
comfortable using the YouTube super chat
either you're not set up for it or you
just have any reason not to do it down
in the description is also a link to my
PayPal and if you put in the memo line
of the PayPal that what you are
contributing is for the fundraiser it
will go towards that I actually got a
donation towards the fundraiser before
the live stream even started through the
PayPal because the person did clarify
that in the in the memo so I I was
already up before I even served which
was amazing you're a youtuber
self-promotion is what you do I think
it's a reflex
this point which is kind of a depressing
thought uh when I have time to breathe
out she's fair enough
yeah Carolyn III appreciate and also
pirates you you you folks you my mods
mean a lot you always do great work
I love how when Sunnydale is destroy
Xandar talks about the stores that are
gone and he mentioned Toys R Us Oh Oh
God
I didn't even remember that ow ow self
promote like how your interview is on my
channel tomorrow I never do stuff like
self promote yes
so I'll once that's up I will link to it
like on the community page and on my
Twitter I did I did an interview with
with Christie Abbey that's going up soon
so that that might be fun I think it
went well
well we'll see how much she had it's me
it's a joke don't worry about it
I just wanted to say how much I love
your videos they make my day inspired me
to become a youtuber best of luck this
gig is it's a weird gig I tell you okay
so if anyone noticed the thumbnail
before we started there was a book that
was in the thumbnail that I wanted to
highlight how goes life life life goes
I'm given where I live a lot of what's
going on isn't directly affecting me I'm
gonna you know I'm gonna try to turn
that light off cuz it is reading to wait
forgive me folks I'm gonna keep
adjusting this see if that does any
better and that's about the same as n't
it maybe it's a little better I don't
know um but anyway have you read any
2080 no I've wanted to for ages Oh
Melinda thank you thank you so much
what is the series you have not done a
review for that don't dang it hang on
this thing won't wear to me here we go
what is the series you have not done a
review for but you would like to do um
ooh
well hmmm there's one that I'm actually
already planning to do a review for that
I haven't and that's galavant I have
very specific plans for talking about
galavant Thank You Adam thank you so
much so oh god I've got two shots I've
got to take now um is that what or - no
this is not water this is not
exceptionally strong though cuz I don't
know how many how many times we're gonna
have to end up doing this room uh oh
gosh this is catching up to me quick um
so galavant is like the big one that
I've actually seen that I'm planning as
far as things that I haven't even seen
yet that I would like to see and them
might do a video on I think probably
Avatar The Last Airbender stop of that
list mmm are you for that and Adam I
will pour yours and put it on hold for a
second so that that first one can go oh
god they're coming in fast
uh I reserve the right to put the shots
on pause if I need to somebody keep
track if I put it on pause in and I need
to catch up okay this is out of left
field but I was wondering if you've ever
seen the movie a time travel the Time
Traveler's Wife if so what did you think
I have seen it I don't love it
part of the reason I don't love it is
that I love the book I read the book
first and the book blew me away I
thought it was phenomenal the movie is
okay the movie stumbles early on because
it it doesn't do a great job of
introducing the whole concept it does it
in a very clumsy fashion whereas the
book was really elegant
and how it introduced the concepts and
and integrated into them into the story
now I mean the casting was good and it
did pretty well after that but that
opening is harsh um oh god Kara you get
you did the level right there's the
beans okay what is the first thing you
want to do go to when lockdown ends um
honestly I just like to go to the movies
what if I got here this might be hang on
this might be grass this looks like
grass to me yeah
Alice grab the resident isn't awful the
grass is one of those ones it's just
kind of odd ah okay
oh god I got catching up to do um so
wait oh god I didn't I didn't take the
shop for Adam yet and there's been whoa
boy
okay this is Adam shot whoo okay so Ben
thank you um I'm gonna have to like do a
count of this like I know there are
people who are good enough at this to
like oh wait there is a guy I do have a
counter haha
holy crap um rock over 200 dollars
already Wow okay geez
this is off to a strong start okay so
Ben it was my birthday very recently and
got a lot of money in addition to lots
of presents so I don't have any excuse
not to do this cheers for this oh my god
thank you
that's oh gosh this is this is kind of
blowing my mind already and
in addition to that Cheers
all right Mitch I'm gonna pour yours and
hold it huh hold on that one for a bit
yeah try and show off the shot glass I
don't know if it's gonna show up blood
it's got the Lord of the Rings engraving
the whole way around because yes I have
very geeky shot glasses Eliza Dushku was
my favorite in Buffy have you ever
watched her other projects true colony
or doghouse I never saw true calling
I did see dollhouse I saw both seasons
of dollhouse that that was an odd show
it wasn't bad and I'm glad I saw it but
it it was hard to get into because the
lead character didn't have a character
of her own for a while and that was kind
of by design and that was an odd way to
go about it so it was interesting that's
what I call dollhouse it was interesting
um so that's Mitch's shot waiting so God
somebody else just came in at that same
level ha ha ha ha
just want to give something Thank You
Sophie I do you think they should rename
season seven of Buffy to the
motivational speech season they could uh
you were gonna talk about the book oh
god yes thank you
sorry um I did not like thank you God's
sake keep me on task you people are
great no need to drink I'm just here to
support thank you much appreciated okay
so this was the book that was in the
thumbnail and this was a book that was
put my hands by Liz that's my partner
and she has a school librarian and this
is a book that I think it's up for the
red clover award which is Vermont
specific but it's already won the
Caldecott and Newbery Honor
and it's called the undefeated and I'm
not going to read it to you because I
don't have permission to do so and it it
would even for fundraising purposes it
would be just wrong of me to use someone
else's work to raise money if I don't
have permission to do that
I would also won Coretta Scott King
award but this book in a very stark way
and in a way that is accessible to all
ages demonstrates the need and the
battle and the struggle for equality so
powerfully that it chokes me out I mean
that it's a picture book it's a handful
of pages and it blew me away how
powerful it was and I think any age I
think if you can get hold of that I put
a link in the description to get it to
be able to get it on Amazon if you want
to do that it is amazing and I highly
recommend it
there's another link I put in the
description as well I'll talk about that
a little later because I'm trying to
pace myself slightly I'm only about 15
minutes in normally I run the live shoes
for about an hour I might go long
depending on how things go so where did
I leave off oh boy such a worthy cause
and thing that's needed at the moment
sending thoughts from the UK I've just
watched Seven Samurai and looking to
delve deeper into Japanese films do you
have a favorite I should be clear but I
haven't seen a ton of Japanese films
that aren't anime if you're asking my
anime favorites it's my neighbor totoro
summer Wars ghost in the shell' be sure
you watch the subtitle of the dubbed a
terrible and get the original if you get
your hands on it not the 2.0 I don't
think that was an improvement really at
all um but as far as Japanese films that
aren't anime I have not rewatched it in
a long time and I'm not
I want to but I did really like Battle
Royale
Rann is very good
I think off the top my head those are
the two main ones that I feel I feel
confident in my memory of them enough to
recommend them so what is this this
looks like could be this could be
sausage that's what I'm thinking maybe
candy floss I don't think so this looks
like the sausage to me all right
oh yeah that's sausage oh boy there's
only one as bad it's just so off-putting
as a as a jelly bean Oh Lord oh jeez hmm
okay ah let's see oh boy
I'm falling behind here which I always
do I was falling behind on jazz but like
it feels more pressing it's time
cotton listening to the Marian
conspiracy the first audio that featured
evil in Smythe honestly not that bad
she's great
and I have a review up for the Marion
conspiracy I'm pretty sure the Ivelisse
mind is great her relationship with the
six start to become baker is a big part
of why he works for me an audio um okay
so this is Mitch so this is a while back
this one and so now
hey the poor one for EM blue horn much
appreciated I'm gonna set that aside for
a moment though see this is why god I'm
working through this bottle holy crap
this is why I I pick things like
schnapps which is low proof
it doesn't mean it isn't still gonna
mess me up thank you very much
Ingrid hello from the UK yes there's
been a lot of amazing solidarity from
the UK that's been really wonderful to
see um you say it doesn't work when an
old villain is killed by a new villain
to show how better they are so I'm
guessing you prefer The Anointed One /
spike and Drusilla well no because The
Anointed One wasn't The Anointed One was
a side feature of the master at best it
wouldn't what I'm talking about would
have been like if the master hadn't been
defeated at the end of season 1 a Buffy
and then spike and Dru rolled up and
killed him
say it's The Anointed One no that's like
the that's like the villains lieutenant
taking over
he wasn't established as an entity into
a in in and of himself for long enough
to have that kick that kind of thing
nice try but no oh god that's also a
ten-dollar okay alright what is this
this huh is that I'm not sure what that
is
looks like marshmallow but it's inverted
this better not be another sausage
huh I'm honestly not sure what that is
is one of the weird ones I'm sure that's
not a standard flavor but like I mean I
don't know what that was Hey okay moving
on and we are over 300 cheese all right
I'm gonna run out of beans and booze at
this rate
have you watched suits if so can we get
a review for it I have not seen suits I
am aware of it I know it exists that's
about all I got do a sponsor Vera for a
new liver next live oh I'll keep you
posted
happy Pride Month and black lives matter
yes thank you and yes have you ever
encountered a film adaptation of a book
that was actually better than the
original novel if so what was it I
personally would argue that Jurassic
Park the movies better than the novel I
think largely just because I think
Steven Spielberg had a much better idea
of the vibe of a notion as ridiculous as
[Music]
you know dinosaur apart full of
dinosaurs you know that on Wonderware as
Michael Crichton he had a tendency to
write things a little bit cold a little
bit clinical I don't think he quite
captured the same level of just fun of
the whole thing actually speaking of
Michael Crichton his own book The Great
Train Robbery he adapted and directed as
a film himself and the movie is better
but that's a weird one because I feel
like he made the improvements to his own
work so I almost feel like that one's
cheating there's probably others but
transnih parts kind of the big one that
people wouldn't know off the top of my
Oh Harry Potter the owner
the Phoenix movies way better the book
was almost insufferable for me oh my god
because okay so the book has a couple of
things going for it the first is what
Liz and I have come to call a caps-lock
Harry his his thoughts and his notions
that are all you know capitalized in
rage and God oh god I hate reading
Harry's thought process in in that book
I really hate it and we don't get that
in the movie we don't get to hear his
stupid stupid stupid angsty stupid
thought process we get spared that which
does wonders and it also was able to
come a lot of the fat because actually
cuz I'm I'm still reading these to my
daughter and we're on the fourth book
and it's slow going cuz honestly
starting with the fourth book there's a
lot of fat on these stories like the
jump from the third to the fourth one is
it's almost night and day because the
first three and I would say the third
one arguably more than any are so tight
like everything is there for a reason
but starting in the fourth one we
started to have things that were there
just because they were expected to be
like Snape really has nothing to do in
the fourth book professor Trelawney has
nothing to do Draco has nothing to do
yet they all eat a page time and you
know page counting word count because
they've always been there but and like
in spew that was a smart cut for the
movie for the fourth movie but so
there's that going on with with order of
the Phoenix as well just stuff that
isn't feeding into the main narrative
but is still there okay I do a bunch of
stuff has come in I can tell because the
dollar amount went up on me
fun fact the author of The Hunger Games
book says she never once read a battle
royale when writing Hunger Kings we just
saw PS I'm not sure I'm necessarily
gonna call BS all night here's what I
would say about that because I've
actually had this happen to me not with
anything I've published thankfully but
like I've had stuff that I wrote it
a couple times I had something that I
like rhoda a short story I had another
thing that I outlined is like a movie
idea and I had something that I wrote as
a bit of stand-up all of which I thought
I had come up with and realized later I
had heard of or heard before I didn't
know them well and I didn't know I was
ripping them off but I'd heard these
terms or concepts or the starting nugget
was definitely completely ripped off and
I didn't realize it cuz I remembered the
thing but not where it came from so it
felt like it was my idea so I actually
kind of believed her when she said she
didn't read it however I can virtually
guarantee you she she heard of it
somewhere along the line and that
embedded it in her head and she doesn't
remember her having heard it which i
think is valid so Wow I think and the
other thing is Hunger Games as far as
what it's doing in the story is telling
is actually doing a very different thing
from battle royale so even though the
core concept is very very very similar
there's enough difference in the overall
approach that I actually I'm okay with
it
despite lucky meadow Roy Allen have you
seen that first thank you very much Lyn
I don't have a question just wanted to
support please everyone stay safe and
sending all my love and support black
lives matter thank you very much I'm you
deserve to better sound off yeah a lot
of Buffy talk this time this is fun like
this I don't need to talk about Buffy
that much um yeah I agree like I've seen
the rationalization for why Joss Whedon
did what he did with Anya I don't agree
but I get why he did it it just doesn't
work for me I'm so sorry I don't have
any money to donate so so I understand
and don't mind if you don't answer my
question as I'm reading your question if
the doctor are generated into a chicken
nugget or candy floss who would you want
I mean chicken nugget at least you can
stand up to being in the rain a little
bit
who would win in a fight Missy or the
master from Buffy all the master would
from Buffy would get obliterated by
Missy he'd never see it coming
okay where are we old villains being
killed by new villains still raw over
Marvel Netflix doing that twice in Luke
Cage and the defenders yes yes I am
especially in the defenders cuz they'd
already done it once and it didn't work
and you did it again
why and for Elektra that's not that I
don't like a lecture but the Netflix
version of Elektra is aggressively
boring ah huh do you oh hang on that's a
that is a bean question ooh this looks
like it's candy floss yes haha a good
jelly bean I swear they cut down the
percentage of actual good ones and this
I'm pretty sure it's a higher percentage
of gross ones it should be an even split
seriously um anyway do you have a
favorite 12th doctor quote or scene
thank you for everything you do stay
safe everyone um that's a really hard
call I think even though I like blip a
little on the idea of children can hear
his name I really like Capaldi's the
final speech in twice upon a time which
is the main reason I can't just regard
cuz like I don't just like twice upon a
time but my general notion is I wish the
dr. Vols had been his last episode I
think it would have been more powerful
to have it happened there but the speech
in toys at one time is great I mean
that's what I put on my ribbon that I
took to Gallifrey 1 back when we could
go to conventions oh and sidebar I
finally finished editing my footage from
that so that'll go up in the break room
leader
this week but you know hate is always
foolish love is always wise and run fast
laugh hard be kind hey mom
okay so that was a beam question me and
my sister and me and my sister are
binging black mirror and chronological
order oh she hasn't seen white Christmas
and she found smithereens depressing
smithereens is depressing white
Christmas was the one that broke me
though ah six ooh yeah thank you
oh god this was poured for whoever was
before that so I got to do that for you
too now oh boy
that's that's dripping um hello from
Uruguay hey um I just wanted to say I
really love your videos in your Shira
video made me cry of happiness oh thank
you so much for liking my art oh yes oh
yes your stuff has been great like keep
doing what you do I'm sorry I didn't
clock that sooner the the chat is far
enough away that I couldn't quite like I
could see you had a drawn avatar but I
couldn't quite make out the art styles
yes yeah I love yes it's fantastic okay
let that sit okay ah did you say that
you finally seen avatar the last name
Airbender might do or review or did I
dream it you misheard I was answering a
question of what things have I not done
reviews for that I might like to and I
answered it in two parts one talking
about something that I have seen and
wanna do a review on which was galavant
and the other mentioning something that
I haven't seen but I suspect what I do I
will want to talk about it that was
avatar I still haven't seen it I do
pretty good for articulation however
many drinks in
[Music]
and thank you Maureen and thank you
Donna
hello I just got my ahsoka tano
lightsabers Oh Oh careful do you want to
get more proficient bring it on oh nice
after finishing Shir I've come to two
conclusions one I need to rewatch it yes
you do too or decadent trapped or the
most powerful chaotic neutral pairing
yeah I mean entrapped especially she's a
hard chaotic neutral holy crap I think
that's probably where were tackle lands
after I like it settling and working off
his uh his evil neutral for a bit but
she'll get him there
okay where am I
which willow is better a normal darker
vampire I'm partial to vampire willow
because I like the board now without the
flame not to say Warren didn't deserve
to be flayed cuz I've noticed one guy
fall on Twitter received death threats
because he defended his father as a good
cop
what's review on d there's no good cop
stance oh god okay I'm not gonna avoid
this question but I'm not gonna do well
on idea there I'm gonna make this as
quick as I possibly can
I am NOT going to give my view on that
because I don't know if I've settled on
one yet what I will say is the reason
for that perspective of there is no good
cop is that is from the view that it is
the current systemic institution of the
police that is the problem and anyone
who is willingly a member of that system
is buying by default part of the system
that is a problem so that's where that
few comes from so I would be cautious
for either you or your friend about
presuming that anyone who says that
simply hate
all cops I'm not to say that there
aren't some people who are like that but
look the whole thing's complicated but
for me the thing to remember is that
that sentiment when applied fairly which
I do believe you actually can apply that
sentiment family fairly it's about
saying that willfully being a part of
that system makes you complicit and
makes you part of the problem I've seen
the position taken and I'm not going to
say that I hold this position cuz again
I don't actually know but I've seen the
position taken that if police officers
honestly think that what's going on is
wrong if they are not in the upper
echelons of power where they can
directly affect change then they would
be most helpful resigning their posts
that staying in place at all even if
they take more passive roles is still
keeping the system in place and again
I'm not saying that that is my viewpoint
I don't know what my viewpoint on that
is I like honestly don't there's too
much I thought it was gonna touch on it
briefly and I went longer than I meant
to or I should have
we're over $350 Wow okay Oh Tracy no
need to drink haha thank you I still got
one to catch up from before before Thank
You Tracy appreciate that I just want to
help I also think say they thank huh say
thanks for hosting this thank you would
you want Missy to face thirteen an
episode if so how with Sasha's master
previous incarnation are on her own um I
don't think I'd want to see Missy face
thirteen because I feel like Missy and
this actually came up with a live stream
and the the panel I was on at web comm
web con the idea that Sasha diwan's
master is somehow inherently
disrespectful to Missy's journey because
she for lack of a better term got better
and then we've got this new masters
right
where he was and part of how I don't
hold that view and part of how I square
that circle is that we don't know where
Sasha fits
Sasha diwan's master we don't know if
he's immediately after Missy we don't
know what has happened like there's
enough wiggle room that I can buy that
sometime between Missy and such the one
if he even comes after which we don't
even know that for a fact
something could have happened and I'm
just and I don't need to know what it is
I don't want to know what it is but that
uncertainty gives me room to think yeah
something happened or a whole succession
of things happened however I do think it
would be disrespectful to bring back
Missy and have her be the way she was
prior to getting better that said I want
another series of Missy on Big Finish
I'm pretty sure they're doing it but
again chronologically that fits earlier
than when she actually started
travelling in the TARDIS with Capaldi's
doctor and what I wish I had more than
anything else was a full series where
Missy was the companion that for me is
the biggest missed opportunity
yeah of new who oh you said that you
prefer angel over Buffy me to you said
you would explain why though um also on
my last donation it was ten dollars love
your reaction ah God okay thank you
start over keeping me honest I think
it's grass again okay there we go
he's candyfloss being me yes you just
say the doctor oh geez
okay so um ask your question as to why I
like angel over Buffy that was
definitely crass and has to do larger
with overall series trajectory because
Buffy II kind of went like this quality
wise second season was better than the
first I actually go back and forth
whether the third is better than the
second sometimes I say it
sometimes I say it isn't but those are
both very good fourth season was rough
fifth season got good again 16 quite
good 7 season aside from the finale I
should think is not very good but angel
I make the argument and people fight me
on this because of Connor but I actually
make the argument that every season is
better than the one before yes including
season poor I'm aware of some of the
shenanigans that went on backstage with
charisma carpenter which were BS but I
still think overall that I thought that
season was phenomenal and I thought the
fifth season the entire fifth season now
it's just the last episode of Angel
which I argue is the one of the best
final episodes in all of television but
that entire season is the best season of
Angel how many shows that go on for more
than like two seasons have their best
season be their last how often does that
happen how I sure didn't either one
Buffy okay where are we is it just me or
did glory not feel that intimidating as
a villain I know she should but I don't
know I actually kind of agree I don't
mind glory a little overrated as a
villain like conceptually I'm on board I
get her cool but you know she just
didn't quite work for me and not not
like for anything that I can really nail
down good I worry Washington while I
think this is cinnamon I'm hoping it is
might also be good know that first one
Oh
huh see I should have gotten myself like
a little bowl to spit these in but I
didn't so I'm making myself swallow them
oh you know what's crazy about the
flavors like earthworm they I've never
eaten an earthworm but they make it
taste like earthworms smell and I don't
know how they do that and yes I know
whatever through him smell like
Highgarden
I don't like gardening but I have a
garden so I have to deal with it huh
now that I have Hulu I recently started
watching Futurama do you have a favorite
episode mines either Paradise Lost with
the worms oh sorry parasites loss with
the worms ironic there and or a fight to
remember the titanic perry um i'm always
partial to the star wars sorry not Star
Wars Star Trek parody but you can't
remember now what the title of that was
I also like uh ferns with para box that
one was a lot of fun and the one with
the the time skips was good I like the
ones where they get more sciency on it
for me talk about the 12th best moment
words for me 12 best moments is his
speech of the last part of flatline I'll
be getting to flatline is a rewatch I'm
hoping like I liked it before but a lot
of people have this best a lot of love
for it so I'm hoping I get a little more
out of it than I remember I'm trying to
donate be a super chat unfortunately
won't work well yeah and there is a link
to my PayPal in the description and Mark
in the memo that is for the fundraiser
and the money will still go towards that
and we are 370
six plus the 20 I know I got through
PayPal
I wonder if four more came in I actually
should check that so I can give people
an accurate total count see if I can get
that to come up give me a second um did
today
come on come on come on come on watching
me try and remember my logins it's uh
really makes for great viewing I still
got a shot there I haven't taken um oh
oh wow Wow holy crap okay hang on the
math um okay 20 90 120
that's 130 bucks in through the paypal
which means that plus the super Chad we
are over 500 holy crap Wow um yeah I've
got no other word beyond that Wow
I'm so close to finishing the first Wow
dang it lost it hang on finding it here
we go I'm so close to finishing the
first episode of an audio series I'm
making during lockdown getting dialogue
from people is so annoying though um I
mean well first of all power to you
because I have audio projects that I
would love to get off the ground but
it's it's a lot of work and honestly in
some ways it's even more unforgiving
than video cuz like my mic that I use
for my videos it has a has an auto gain
function that I can't turn off and I
don't want to have to spring for all in
mic and I get away with it in video
because because you're looking at me you
don't always notice or it's not as
immediately apparent the at you know the
the gain went up a little bit and like
the white noise of the room is coming in
a little louder than it should but if
all you've got is the audio and you
don't have the visual to fall back on
you know is that so hard so you know
power to you would you rather be a Sith
or a Jedi
well if Jedi's actually get to do the
mind trick I'll be Jedi and spam the
heck out of that doesn't feel like a
light like side of the force power but
hey they get away with it if I can do
that I'll be happy
does the donate feature pull up for
every user regardless of whether payment
accounts are connected or not I'm trying
to figure out if I can donate or not um
actually don't know again there's the
PayPal if you want to go that route if
the super chat is giving you trouble how
do you think they will bring Steve
Trevor back in next Wonder Woman I have
no idea I'm really curious to find out I
just hope it doesn't make me roll my
eyes
I doubt it but have you seen the 1972
film sleuth I would recommend it but so
hard to get a hold of I have and I've
seen the remake
I caught sleuth back when I was getting
Netflix through mailed discs cuz I'm old
I would say I had a membership to
Blockbuster except they didn't cuz I
live in a small town there is no
blockbuster there was however a local
store called video King up until last
year hung on for a while which version
of the doctor would you have crossover
with shira I will go with 9 he could use
the lightness her Nolan and trapped
would both fawn over tech rather than
save people ooh that's a good question I
heard I would be inclined to say - I
kinda wanna see troughton because as
light and goofy as he is he likes to be
the light and goofy one in the room I
think of other people were being the
like goofy ones it would throw them off
and if the way that'd be very funny have
you seen sense 8 I've seen the first
episode about a year ago and I need to
get back to it probably need to rewash
that episode - it's on the to-do list
he's creeper did a video where he tried
to detail the character history of the
doctor using the different methods have
you seen it I'm not sure I've seen that
one so no no I haven't I live in
Scotland and under Trump your country is
a complete and utter mess sync over 19
affecting your country the most out of
and he is incredibly sad well I mean
those two things aren't unconnected it's
been months and my main takeaway is
still being salty that Ruth didn't turn
out to be a bigger deal I mean to be
fair shipping was time isn't done and
she may yet turn out to be a bigger deal
I'm
hoping cuz she's great so you know
fingers crossed
alright I've been sitting on this one
for awhile so let me do this that should
catch me up on drinks uh thoughts on new
Big Finish out of time dr. four and ten
and masterful multi-master fiftieth
anniversary
wish I could donate but I'm also doing
other important things learning
listening etcetera
no worries John um I want to hear both
of them those are my only thoughts until
I hear them I won't really have more
thank you a bavin hope I hope I didn't
butcher that um I don't have a question
I just wanted to donate thank you for
doing this and you don't have to eat a
bean at this point I'm kind of dreading
the beans more than the fourth of the
booze how do you think oh no I answered
that um Thank You Christy fine to watch
life on Mars ashes to ashes I've been
told that for a very very very long time
it didn't realize until it was pointed
out the girl who waited parallels the
situation eleven has with River he can't
save melody from the silence without
causing River to not exist Oh cramp
that's true oh thank you
according to a shot and the Doctor Who
spin-off class Susan Foreman has passed
away it was in her old school honestly
I'm just ashamed cope Holly didn't
acknowledge it when he appeared in class
if that is their cannon yeah that would
be annoying given how few people watched
class I think they can easily sweep that
under the rug if they ever decide to
Susan's one of those things that I'm
kind of two minds about at this point
it's been so long that it might be
better to not go there um but on the
other hand you know there's that
one day I shall come back yes I will
come back you know he stood which
character for my past doctor iteration
be the companion ally or enemy do you
think would have the best chemistry with
thirteen who would you want to see
thirteen reunite with hmm I kind of like
I'm not sure I need them to go on
adventure I kind of want to see what Amy
would say seeing 13 I don't know if
she'd have the best chemistry but I'd be
super curious I've started angel
actually that was a bold move what they
did with Doyle so early in the season
mmm so unfortunately put it behind the
scenes on that it is good I agree what
they did was very good but that wasn't
part of the original intent and plan
because the actor had substance abuse
problems and the decision was made that
he wasn't reliable enough to keep around
and he was written out of the show far
earlier than you know anyone had thought
when he was originally hired so I agree
it was very well done it's well acted
and if you didn't know that there there
was a decision outside of just the
narrative utility of doing that that
kind of made that call yeah
it's bold as the twelfth doctor said
Garden has just dictatorship yeah that
kind of his Wow I'm Way behind in the
chat if getting gardening comments how
do you think oh yeah I read that and I
answered that okay
backing up backing up back camp did you
ever watch the 1985 Gordon film nope I
know the song
ah can't sing any more than that I
managed to donate via PayPal Thank You
Ian
I appreciate that Alexa okay Oh before I
forget I mentioned that there was one
other piece of work that I listed in the
description that I wanted to mention
there is a friend of mine who actually
lives in Vermont and does burlesque
their name is hi-ho silver and they did
a number tail end of last year so
obviously before quarantine which was
about police brutality and their
experience as a black person and sort of
processing through some of that by way
of a burlesque number and they recently
posted that that performance to their
Instagram and I have linked down below
now be aware hey it's a broiler so
not-safe-for-work
and be content warning you know they're
the number deals with racism and
violence so Wow
it's not gory or anything like that it
is those are very central to what it is
so if you are okay with and know that
going in and aren't watching it at work
I highly recommend watch you need click
and following that link in watching
their number cuz it's it's really
amazing okay here we go yeah I just had
to suppress a burp so which I then told
you about which made the suppression
point is as well just let it rip Oh God
thank you for using your platform to
contribute to the cause youtubers like
you make YouTube so much more than
entertainment thank you Sam oh boy we
got I think what is that I think this is
black pepper
yeah
again not bad um weird
mm I might still probably still wrap up
the the stream not too far after 8
o'clock Eastern Standard you know too
much past an hour just because you know
we had initial it's third why do I get a
lisp when I drink surge and things seem
to have dial back that's not me being
like oh you stop doing any I'm ending it
like these things are normally an hour
so just set expectations favorite
non-fiction book nonfiction oh man see
that's tough because like all my really
favorite stuff is fiction I'm gonna just
rattle off some that I like because I
can't pick a favorite I'll tell my head
if Chin's could kill Bruce Campbell's
memoir I really liked born a crime which
was Trevor Noah's memoir which was
fantastic
let's go those off to tell my head and
under her current circumstances I'm
gonna recommend born a crime it's really
good I listened to it on audio and he
reason it's great and it's heavy and
it's a lot it's really good uh let's see
I am working on Avatar The Last
Airbender for a series on my channel
about watching old shows thoughts on the
show I haven't seen it mm-hmm mm-hmm
as my super chat popped up I haven't
seen any more um I'm just seen it
Charleston hold on I'm trying to scroll
back through
I don't see it unless it was a like ways
ways back um I'm keeping an eye out
though I'm also not caught up so it
might have popped up later uh let's see
uh if you could have lunch with one
Doctor Who actor or actress Dead or
Alive which would you choose and why my
as Matt Smith alright I think I still
gotta go Capaldi like it's so funny to
me because I didn't take to him right
off and it was a while before I really
sunk in how much I liked him
cuz I had to basically get to the end of
his run and not that he was suddenly
growing at the end was like it was the
journey and like I'm so attached to that
doctor now it's it's it's kind of crazy
who would win in a contest of
inspirational speeches 12 or Buffy I
think 12 I feel like he can hold the
stage a little longer than then Buffy
can but Buffy gives good speeches but
they're kind of they kind of build to
and let's go and that's always kind of
what punctuated her speeches and if so
if it was a contest that doesn't like
isn't just her talking people into
battle and she just has to stay on stage
she'd lose her wind a little bit I have
you seen Dark City and if so how do you
feel about the director's cut if you
have seen it I have seen Dark City I
didn't know there was a director's cut
I'd have to see what the differences are
I'm pretty sure what I have is the
theatrical I like the first two-thirds
of it immensely I'm not gonna say what
the point is cuz it's a spoiler but I
can pinpoint to the minute the point of
which the thing started to lose me and
then the climax it almost completely
lost me which annoyed me because I was
loving the hell out of it out
that point I'm the aesthetic on it's
incredible like it's it I own it so I
still like it I just you know turn it
off two-thirds of the way yeah could it
be ha it could it be a possibility that
when the plane exploded it actually made
him travel to 1980 400 you talking to
Steve Trevor I mean I guess but there
was nothing magical on that plane that
we know of so that would be happy
convenient it took me a second to catch
up with you can't imagine why
Veeran nothing in the discord show off
your new hair and said up Thank You
Carolyn for checking that for me and yes
went darker this time did the the
heavier blue and brought the purple back
which I haven't had for a while because
I did the pink four ways there but I
like I like it it's a unless unless I
really put it right up front it it's
sort of more work to notice that it's
there which I kinda like a little bit
like out of the corner of your eye you
wouldn't mean you think uh dyed hair
like hey Tam init which kind of really
dig oh my HUD see quick Big Finish
recommendation I am the master
it's wouldn't it's written written and
starring Jeffery beavers and it's only a
couple of pounds or dollars I might look
into it I've got a backlog of Big Finish
stuff that I already have and I haven't
gotten to yet
so I'm trying not to accumulate more
because I had a tendency to do that with
video games
I have games on ps2 I never got around
to playing I've got games on my ps3 that
I really want to try and find the time
for I ain't getting a new I ain't
getting anything newer for the night
reason aside from the obvious financial
one are you so excited for Time Lord
victorious honestly I hope
way to fit Frobisher and oh that would
be amazing the world needs more
Frobisher and if you don't know who
Frobisher is Frobisher
from Doctor Who he's appeared in comic
books and audio adventures he is they
shape-shifting penguin who talks like a
Brooklyn detective from the 1940s and
it's great you know how I said you know
how I said I once wanted a Lovecraft
historical Big Finish are now doing one
I'm a little nervous about it I know I
know how you mean been there's always
that thing like oh I wish they'd do this
idea then you find out you know
somebody's doing it and you suddenly get
very nervous like oh my god I hope this
thing that I've been hoping for for so
long
works because then if it stinks that's a
really gonna sting that's a big part of
me and series 11 cuz I've talked about
this before and I I was gonna say I
won't dwell on it I don't know if I will
cuz I'm not keeping track of a lot at
this point um but you know series 11 I'm
doctor who did so many things that I
wanted the show to do you know ditching
the the series arc mostly self-contained
stories no returning monsters all of the
all of these are things I wanted the
show to do and it did them I didn't like
it would you rather have Ian and Barbara
back than Susan to be honest oh I would
like Anton Barbara back and I want them
to ask about Susan that's what that's
what I want to see happen and I wanna
see whatever doctor they ask I want to I
want to be able to read the world on
their face do you know how fast you were
live-streaming
I swear officer I I didn't know so it
seems like donations have mostly wrapped
up which is fine
we raised over five hundred dollars at
this it might even be up to six I
haven't checked the PayPal
I will tweet out what we got out to I'm
gonna try and catch the last few
questions anybody wants to get other
donations in fantastic if not thank you
this okay what's going to be interesting
about masterful is where is we're
getting a whole new incarnation a child
version which I believe will be a
version of the master that appeared in
the comics
I'd heard something about that I don't
know much about it though ranking the
burden Schumacher Batman films Batman 89
Batman Forever Batman Returns Batman and
Robin
imagine if Merlin and galavant were in
the same time when they crossed over who
that'd be fun
do you want space wives 13 and River to
be a thing I don't need it favorite
didn't I wouldn't be against it but I
don't need it what do you think of the
idea of remaking a little shop of
horrors why like that's my only idea hi
struggling with super chat so we'll pay
later I have a few comedies I'd like you
to see but I'm scared you might not like
them any rule of thumb for what you're
most likely to enjoy um my tasting
comedy tends to be rapid-fire and witty
I don't like I like I hate humiliation
humor I do not like cringe comedy I I
I like wordplay I like rapid-fire banter
I don't like stoner comedy I think that
kind of gives you the broad strokes if
you want to thank see your question I
recommend saying at Council of geese
before it's having a question and I
might even read you explaining that to
someone haha my super Jack question what
the bleep America
I don't know Big Finish amounts of Missy
series two years and the meddling monk
is definitely coming back yes oh that
was so much fun
sixes coat with blend in well in atheria
but I really want Pertwee and Shira ooh
he'd assumed Skorpio is a monster of the
week he'd usually be fighting she just
uh him haha also please do the other war
master series I need to get them thank
you for doing this stream is such a
strong force for good and full of kind
people with such lovely messages so this
was such a caring thing to do thank you
dr. LOH adventures my Wi-Fi is going in
and out suddenly it's a good look and
I'll see you on video tomorrow Thank You
Christy um what is your favorite
conspiracy theory I don't have one cuz
conspiracy theories are dumb ma I'm
sorry I can't even entertain them for
fun I think that might even be part of
why I don't get into fan theory very
much they too closely resemble
conspiracy theories you must be the
sixth person the doctor trusted the most
um cheese more donations thank you Wow
alright where did I leave off okay I
might have to give up trying to catch
all the questions cuz obviously more
coming in
[Music]
when you said Frobisher I was thinking
John Frobisher from Torchwood children
of Earth and shape-shifting penguin
really threw me for a loop you try and
convince me that Ruth is a good doctor
Joe Martin is great actress but I'm not
gelling with how rough she is in times
of the time and tied to the timeless
child which I kind of despise I can't
convince you that she's a good doctor
because I don't know if she is my thing
is I love her presence I want to see her
be the doctor you need to realize up to
this point all we've really seen her do
is clash with another version of the
doctor and the doctor tends to not get
along with himself so that shouldn't
necessarily be taken as standard for how
that doctor I actually behaves my thing
is I love her presence so much I want
more can I make an argument for why
she's a good doctor no but I can tell
you from the vibe I get off her I want
to believe that she could be good I want
to see her be good putting in a little
extra bit just to say well done for
doing this thank you Kara
thank you Oh God Thank You pirates I
like to Commission you for some comedies
but I've kind of scale yeah I answer
that I recently saw a live stream with
you on an online panel discussing doctor
who was wondering if you would continue
to be involved with online discussions
since it was really cool oh yeah the the
panel was a lot of fun I really enjoyed
the the web con panel I'd love to do
more stuff like that I mean I enjoyed
the panel I did a Gallifrey one I I'm
totally up for that
yeah I'm trying I'm trying to spread out
a little bit more and get more involved
with other people who have me what if
the way the doctor and the master got
their names from when they played as
children I don't I don't care how the
doctor and the master got their names I
just don't
their names say everything about them
how they got them I don't care I don't
care for the same reason I didn't care
how Han Solo got his name the name said
everything you needed to know about
finding out that it basically got put in
as a clerical filler I don't care I
don't mean that to be belittling towards
you but I just that question my answer
is I don't care what's worst Disney
live-action remake or six fires of the
Caribbean movie I haven't seen most of
the Disney live-action remade so I
couldn't actually tell you I can tell
you that fundamentally philosophically
their existence annoys me more than more
parts of the Caribbean does no question
that just thanks for using your platform
thank you Kelly
sorry for the ophtho off-topic question
do we don't even really have a topic for
this one um but do you think that Disney
should continue trying to make more Star
Wars media or do you think they're
milking the series dry I mean look
they're going to make more I think they
shouldn't make another movie for a while
I think they should stick things like
the Mandalorian work in some other media
for a while
hold off before doing a movie again
that's the that's the delivery method I
think they need to give a rest for right
now
why build the livestreams remain every
two weeks even in lockdown because I'm
still working a and B the reason it
became every other week is because I
used to have to move the time around
oh hi Jesse I used to have to move the
time around because I have my kid every
other week and I had to move it to later
because I wanted her to be in bed before
I did it and I still have her every
other week so locked down did 0-2 impact
to the reasons why the live stream is
every two weeks that's why I feel like
it came off snarky or snippy with that
answer I apologize I can be a surly
drunk I don't know if I'm drunk I don't
I'm actually not really gonna find out
until I stand up that's usually when I
find out how drunk I actually am when I
try and get on my feet
let's see-oh cuddley heart hug thing
thank you
actually and that means uh-oh what is
this that looks blueish who I might be
blueberry yeah that's blueberry cool I'm
over that sending love to all of you in
Council of weeks thank you so much
Jessie let's see have you ever heard
listen to heard of the Magnus archives a
great horror podcast with great lgbtq+
representation I think it's writer I
want its writers to write an episode for
Doctor Who I feel like I've heard the
name I know nothing about it though um
let's see we know how the doctor and the
master got their names they chose them
well yes we do know that but like there
could theoretically be a story as to why
they decided those were the names they
wanted so again if there is a story I
don't want to know it
have you heard the rumor Karen Gillan
will be the star in the Pirates of the
Caribbean reboot
nope that's news to me I personally like
the theory that the maximum that arcs
origins are constantly changing due to
time travel meddling I'm gonna buy that
I don't I I just need to not know the
origin I don't even need that it just
needs to be something I don't know I'm
gonna recommend the remake of the jungle
book and Cinderella no they aren't straw
Prashar remakes I actually try to do
something different I don't care I don't
care they're still treading and they
exist to recreate the iconography of the
originals so I don't care the only the
only two that I'm prepared to give a
pass to and one of them is tentative
they give a pass to Maleficent because
that is a wildly different beast from
the original film and I am prepared to
give a pass to Milan
depending on what I think what I
actually see because having seen the
trailer it seems to really just be
taking the concept in doing it fresh
from the ground up it's not treading on
the same iconography last I knew they
weren't using the songs not really which
is what they should they should not be
reusing those songs so I'm prepared to
be nicer to that one and maybe actually
even see it but Cinderella jungle book I
don't care don't care don't want it oh
thank you Cathy oh boy oh we got it wait
wait oh god I think it's so yeah
ooh yeah Wow
that's another one a little bit like the
vomit it's not on the back end of it
really sure oh we are a little bit of
the fuzziness a little bit of a little
bit of fuzziness I'm not surprised
you're picking up on that heroin why is
the ROM oh he's gone
oh that's why oh why is the rum gone I
really do love that first movie as much
as the franchise got run into the ground
I love that first movie so much uh see
mister my donation did I
I thought I'd get me there were a couple
from you Oh No there it is
Thank You Starkiller thank you sorry
have you listened to stand up if so
favorite comedian yes favorite comedian
of all time
probably George Carlin the stuff towards
the end of his life I don't like as much
but man the guy redefines stand-up and
rightfully so some of the ones I really
like I love Eddie Izzard
I think he's phenomenal depending on my
mood I like a bit of Louis black but I
mean George Carlin
yeah he's where it's at thank you for
bringing that to my attention sorry I
missed it I'm keep trying to keep up
with this thing the blue ones are the
best cuz you sent you to get blueberry
or mint sent me love from Ireland thank
you
it's amazing listen to it Jesse I feel
like you you're my relationship is
starting to become a back and forth of
you don't know this yet check it out and
then me going you don't know that yet
let's podcast mine I feel like that this
is gonna become our relationship now I I
told you that I'm a sucker for westerns
like you're a sucker for pirates I'm
gonna tell you two of my favorite
westerns back to the future part three
nice Ballad of Buster Scruggs ice
seen that I should story of the name
civil they're both narcissists I could
buy that I say I rather seen Karen
Gillan has poison ivy and suicide squad
two men being another papyrus movie oh I
want that now
did you watch the Netflix series of
unfortunate events I watched I think
three episodes then they seemed pretty
good but I just I wasn't feeling it to
keep going
they were fine but I wasn't sucked in I
never read the books I was too old for
the one they came out Sean Pertwee has
been back and forth on whether he played
the third doctor on Doctor Who
would you want him to I think he could
be fantastic but I get why he's not sure
on it um if anyone was going to play the
third doctor it should be him I'm not
sure if I wanted in the abstract and
honestly I would like him to play the
doctor but I would like him to play his
own doctor not his father he was on my
list of actors who I would love to see
play the doctor cuz I want to see what
he does with it even though I'm sure he
could do a great version of his father
Rob Lewis was one of my favorites he was
good I actually like the idiots lanterns
and fear her
Timms it almost take a shot on principle
there okay starting again I actually
like the idiots Lantern and fear her
because the only Doctor Who DVDs I had
included them so that meant constantly
watches oh okay see that's valid that's
fair uh actually I'll give you a pass on
that you had me worried there for a
minute have you ever seen Gallagher nope
those are the best kinds of
relationships oh good ah happy Pride
Month thank you
let it never be forgotten the first
pride was a riot young George Carlin is
the best I loved his bits about time
driving and all the oddball stuff he
talked about John mulaney's probably my
favorite comedian though John Mulaney is
really good yeah I've enjoyed him on and
I'm actually kind of with you I'm like I
feel like my personal favorite stuff of
George Carlin is his earlier stuff and
what you were probably lump under his
goofy stuff phase I'm using a different
word than he used but at one point he
said my job basically is thinking of
goofy stuff and you know you don't have
time a week so on the weekends I write
down the goofy stuff and I come around
and report it to you cuz on Netflix I
reckon you would love the British sitcom
dinnerladies don't know that one have
you read the new Hunger Games book it's
great I haven't read any of the Hunger
Games books I've seen the first two
movies it's Shearer Smith for a second
doctor um I love him actually guess
because he was the one who did it and
Adventure space in time it was fine I
didn't love him did you know Rimmer
Furman bred dwarf almost played the
Ninth Doctor really under normal
circumstances they
say citation needed but I'm just gonna
choose to believe that when Robin
Williams was playing his alien character
and spoke gibberish she was actually
swearing different languages I heard
that there's a podcast I listened to
called your brain on facts that had the
Moxie did an episode a while ago about
curses in different languages and she
brought that up that tickled me I'm
promoting so much stuff that I feel like
I've never talked about on this show
before this is this feels good
my favorite stand-up comedian is Frankie
Boyle though I don't blame anyone who
doesn't like him I'm not sure I know him
have you watched killing Eve nope
loved you Jesse and Steven Jesse Star
Trek video oh thank you Michael that was
a lot that was a lot of fun I enjoy
doing that I do think like I do think
that both Jesse and Steve blew my
performance out of the water
know who is your least favorite doctor
and companion like as a duo or
individually cuz if you're saying as
individually I can't make that call
because I haven't seen all the
companions least favorite doctor at
present is the war doctor as a pairing I
don't know this doctor with most of the
campaign's I've seen him with hasn't
done much for me to be honest although
God there's also a seventh and Mel
ever seen screen with a shout cut yes I
have I need to re-watch it I haven't
seen it in ages um but like that's on
the that's on the eventual to-do list as
like a Doctor Who oddities excuse me
thing I really should wrap up did did
you do the Buffy charity stream with
some of the other actors and actresses
it was so cool no I missed that
oh wow a whole lot of questions okay I
need I need to wrap this up soon folks I
believe Chris Barry was also considered
for the eleventh Doctor by Steven Moffat
Oh huh what is the point of the cheese
guy in the buffy of the episode Restless
nothing cheese guys the one thing that
doesn't mean anything
because there's always one element in
your dreams that is bizarre comes out of
nowhere it means nothing
killing Eve has the issue that it treads
a lot of the same ground as Hannibal oh
not nearly as much style Oh see that
would be rough for me then because I
really liked Hannibal if I were stand-up
comedian I probably start to to tell
that the setup comedian then moved to
another setup I'm not sure I follow that
I either read it wrong or I can't wrap
my head around what was said or I don't
know I recommend killing you Eve morbid
humor you might like maybe next time you
rank the doctors will you factor in Big
Finish you've heard yes I have before
and I will do you plan to source your
characters or into Hogwarts houses not
only do I plan to do it I've already
shot it gotta edit it yeah uh have my
chance watch the Eddie Izzard series the
riches yes I have there's a lot of
little touches I like about it as an
overall thing it's okay
are there any trans people you would
like to play the doctor excluding
yourself
dang it um I don't know if top my head
because and like this this makes me a
bad queer there aren't that many trans
actors who I know by name and can think
about my head while inebriated because
you know my first restriction that I've
always said is the doctor needs to be
British somewhere in the British Isles
anywhere doctor it can be Welsh
Irish doctor it's fine but needs to be
from there and I'll top my head
other than Laura Kate Dale he doesn't
act I don't know
often Tom my head too many other trans
people from that region I know they
exist I just can't think of them I've
done my head would you ever make a
subreddit haha no no I have enough
trouble juggling everything I have and I
wouldn't I wouldn't ask anyone else to
mod it for me I've got enough stuff like
I I get enough wonderful backup from
from pirates and from Karen here
I wouldn't ask them or anyone else
d'amato subreddit for me and I don't
have the time to do myself so just no
not with my life as it as it currently
exists because like that's the kind of
thing that maybe I consider doing if
this was my living and I didn't sell
have a full-time job or more accurately
didn't still need a full-time job
couldn't do do you have a flag I don't
need a flag this is our country no flag
no country you can't have one that's the
rule that I just made up really wish we
still had George Carlin and Robin
Williams right now I really would love
to hear their opinions on Trump when you
realize Chuck Berry dropped Johnny be
good a week before Marty McFly played it
at the enchants under the sea dance ah
Bradley Walsh who plays Gramm was
pranked on his own game show by British
duo Ant & Dec I would recommend it it's
so funny depends on the nature of the
prank I very iffy on pranks as a general
rule as you like a lot of British
culture especially shows like that of
Doctor Who
are your thoughts on an American as an
American on the royal family and that
side of British tradition I don't have
too many thoughts because since I'm so
detached from that tradition in that
culture I thought so very much those of
an outsider and they're very much
filtered through me having seen other
people talk about it so my personal
uninformed inclination is that if you
are claiming to not have a classist
Society
to literally have a royal family seems
inherently contradictory to that even if
they don't hold official power you know
in terms of ruling but again that is the
uninformed opinion of someone who has
not studied not heard a lot of arguments
from a lot of sides like that if I if I
was sober I probably would have declined
to answer that completely have you arch
snowpiercer
I'm assuming you mean the new show that
has started no I've seen the movie movie
was great could there ever be a doctor
or a doctor from Gibraltar or the
Falkland Islands moving on what are your
thoughts on Helena Bonham Carter as
Bellatrix Lestrange I thought she did
pretty good worked for me okay I need I
need to wrap this up have you ever had
anyone choose the $600 a month patreon
option yes once remember last year that
I did I took up re watching every film
in the Harry Potter franchise including
both fantastic beast movies that was on
on a whim that was because somebody
actually took up the highest support
tier that I have for one month in order
to Commission me to do the whole series
so I I hope they feel like they got
their money's worth as someone from New
Hampshire who seriously wants to play
the doctor I have to disagree about the
native UK actor thing yeah but I have
some very deep roots in the UK which I'd
consider fine I mean depends on your
definition of deep roots because
depending on how you look at it I have
deep roots in the UK my family came over
on the Mayflower I can trace my roots
back to the UK I still wouldn't hire me
to play the doctor
not really but everyone ever wants to
cast me in like a a fan series to play
an off canon doctor hit me up I'll do it
but you know they essentially hijacked
the show and make everything go wrong
huh okay all right I really gotta wrap
this up I do wish we could see the Eric
Holtz cut back to the future they didn't
finish filming with him but they said
like two weeks from finishing shooting
I've seen some shots I mean if they
didn't like it I'm not surprised they
never released it calling it now Hordak
has a Hufflepuff on your list well tune
in and see you you're wrapping up board
now thank you for ending this oh my god
I think I've actually caught up have you
seen 19:17 yet no I haven't I think I
think I'm half Scottish if you don't
know could it really be a full half I'm
just saying you sound like me reading a
book just one more chapter okay I think
we're gonna wrap it up so actually
before I do I'm gonna see if I can get
back to the PayPal real quick see if I
can get a final tally for you folks
looks like 589 is where we came in
so thank you everybody that huh I didn't
know what this would bring in so I got
to get that I got to get that transfer
that PayPal gotta move some stuff around
but I should I actually should be able
to cover that amount to make the
donation to black visions collective by
Friday at the absolute latest yeah Wow
Wow um good night yes thank you
if I play the dark to keep in my head
live in South Carolina I want them to be
like the most sarcastic a whole towards
other people what a total sweetheart
just companions maybe Vera it'll be over
600 in a few haha so I'll tell you what
I'll probably I'll probably put out the
tweet officially announcing what we were
raised tomorrow morning so that I can
give time for any lingering things to
come in and clear thank you
as somebody who you know just like I
said at the beginning isn't the voice
you should be listening to I I didn't
know what kind of impacts you folks cuz
I was gonna say I could make you would
make through me and through this and you
thank you what you've done is a
wonderful thing and uh uh-huh
thank you randomness make it 591 uh all
I did was give you folks a means to do
something wonderful and a help so thank
you for that hope everybody has a good
night stay safe and be well and remember
that you're beautiful you are valid you
are loved you are the counsel I just run
the meetings so until next time this
council is adjourned
hi folks
you